vor einigen tagen habe ich schon mal ein
synonyme video mit aktuell und schenkens
hochgeladen
da so viele von euch das video mega mega
lustig fahren haben wir uns gedacht wir
reden einen zweiten teil dann ist mir
jedoch im schnitt und auch schon bei der
aufnahme aufgefallen
das ist so witzig das könnte auch eine
versuche nicht zu lachen challenge sein
also jetzt beginnt das video und
versuchst einfach nicht so lange genug
haben meine liebe freunde ich jetzt hier
wieder der unschlagbaren kombination mit
schenkers hat einen iq so hoch wie
teppichkanten luca ist so überflüssig
wie ein fundbüro in polen abdel wenn
sein gesicht auf einer briefmarke wäre
würde die post pleite gehen
doch die hastig habe ab 0 jetzt das ist
das ist ein ganz anderes video
die samen die konten nein tun wir nicht
warum gibt es in die hand cola limonade
koffeinhaltige getränk coca cola pepsi
coca cola adidas ist durchgehend ist auf
einmal waren einmal weiter auf einmal ob
er also fritz kola afrika jetzt klar
machen merkt jetzt bezüglich
erfrischungsgetränk mit
pflanzenextrakten ja sogar einziges
[Musik]
erfrischungsgetränk mit pflanzenextrakt
in klammern explizit vom kokablatt usa
seien sie ist ja eigentlich voll schere
darf entscheiden
ok - meist nach hinten gucken haben
[Musik]
auto das hatten wir letztes mal das darf
man keine englischen dürfe kein mobiler
kraftfahrzeug person kraftfahrzeug
mobilität gegenstand vierrädrige wenn du
dich weiter liche er ist last chaos
morgen ich das ist doch ein 11
ich weiß überhaupt nichts rein gar
nichts
[Musik]
apfel
kürzlich musste er gar nicht rot rotes
fruchtzucker und steinobst steinobst
okay
[Musik]
frucht
zigarette glimmt der kippe
[Musik]
da sah letzte runde sagen wir werden
jetzt falsch - 70 sich peter handy
mobilgerät mobiltelefon wird ja noch
schlecht halten wir überlegt was sie
selbst nicht zurück so durchgezogen
jede kommunikationsgerät das hat sich im
kopf hat ich bin stark gefordert ab wird
immer nach einer gewissen zeit und noch
mal unter druck setzen und der checker
so waren wir sind was wir im film
rundfunkgeräte annehmen
kommunikationsgerät ist das nicht so hat
der kontinente und meditation hatte
felix ok hatten fakt dann bin ich raus
55 sekunden nach jetzt ja was hast du in
sachen nicht damit dass heute wieder so
verbindet jemand wolle werde ich weiter
jetzt welche normale punktestandes
möchte für die gefahr dass auf jeden
fall gerne einen daumenbruch bad ems
kanal zu verlieren ganz kalt in der
beschreibung schränke liegen auch ein
video des tages menschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend
[Musik]